in this lesson we're going to talk about
probability now probability is something
that you definitely want to know for the
math section of the act so let's define
probability so probability equals the
number of successes okay what you want
divided by the total possible outcomes
so the total number of things that could
occur so again probability is what you
want over the total
so let's look at a couple examples see
if you can pause the video for a moment
and see if you can solve these couple
examples we'll go through them together
so the first one says in a hat there are
slips of papers
numbered one through seven what is the
probability that if you reach in the hat
blindfolded that you pick an even number
okay so let's list out all the possible
things that could happen you could
basically get a one a two a three a four
a five a six or a seven right so it
looks like there's seven total possible
outcomes so that's the denominator but
how many even numbers are there there's
two there's four and there's six so
there's three even numbers so the
probability of picking an even number
would be three-sevenths
okay let's look at example number two
so this one they give us this region
here and it says if you throw a dart at
the board what is the probability that
you land in the shaded region assuming
that you hit the square you know region
so basically you're throwing a dart okay
you're going to land somewhere in this
square
okay
but what's the probability that you land
just in the shaded part okay now this
one is more like a geometric type of
probability problem and what you want
here is you want the area
of success okay that's the area that you
know that you're aiming for the area
that you want divided by the total
possible area so i'll just write total
area so in this case to find the shaded
region we're going to take the area of
the square which is 12 times 12 since
it's a square so that's 144
minus the part that we're removing which
is the circle now the circle has a
radius of 6 inches and the area of a
circle is pi r squared so this is going
to be pi times 6 squared
all divided by the total area which is
again the 144. so if we simplify this
down we get 144
minus 36 pi divided by 144 and that's an
exact answer now you can do it on your
calculator and you'll get a decimal
approximation but
oftentimes on the act they might just
leave it as an exact value or exact
answer like that so again probability
definitely something you want to know
for the ect easy questions to get right
i'll see you in the next lesson